اذا وصلنا السلاح بشكل مستعجل والصواريخ
بعيده المدى نبعدهم عنود فحسب بل سنبدا في
نهايه
اوكرانيا تعرف الاحتياجات الخاصه بذلك نحن
ممتنون لجميع الدول التي تسير على هذا
الطريق بجانبنا
المفوضيه الاوروبيه تتحدث عن عقوبات
اضافيه على روسيا وعن ضروره دفعها 8 ما
تفعله حربها في اوكرانيا
ناقشنا خلال هذه القمه طريقه المثلى لجعل
روسيا تدفع ثمن التدمير الهائل الذي
احدثته في اوكرانيا نحن نستعرض مع شركائنا
الخيارات المتاحه لتحقيق ذلك الجاني يجب
ان يدفع الثمن وان يخضع للمسائله ويرى
الاتحاد الاوروبي ان اوكرانيا في طريقها
اليه
ان مستقبل اوكرانيا هو الاتحاد الاوروبي
ومستقبل الاتحاد هو اوكرانيا وقدركم هو
قدرنا نقول ان الاتحاد الاوروبي سيدعم
اوكرانيا في كافه مراحل انضمامها للاتحاد
الاوروبي ولسنا خائفين من روسيا والكرملين
تقول السلطات الاوكرانيه ان هذا اللقاء
يكتسي اهميه بالغه وتعلق عليه امالا كبيره
لزياده الدعم العسكري الاوروبي لاوكرانيا
لاسيما مع احتدام المعارك شرقا وجنوبا وفي
ضوء تقارير تتحدث عن استعداد روسيا لشن
هجوم على اوكرانيا بالتزامن مع الذكرى
الاولى للحرب
فبينما كان لقاء منعقدا كانت سفارات
الانذار تدوي في العاصمه وبقيت المعارك
العنيفه مستمره في الجنوب في انتظار
الاسلحه النوعيه والثقيله التي تقول ان من
شانها وحدها قلب المعادله
حول استمرار الدعم المالي لاوكرانيا
بحزمات المساعده التي اعلن عنها الاتحاد
الاوروبي اضافه للدعم العسكري الذي تقدمه
الدول الاوروبيه تعتبر امرا شديد الاهميه
لاوكرانيا في فتره الحرب وستمكنها من
تحرير كافه اراضيها
تقر اوكرانيا بان المعارك على الجبهات
تزداد صعوبه كل يوم وتكثف في موازاتها
حملتها الدبلوماسيه لاقناع حلفائها بان
امدادها بالاسلحه المتطوره لا يورطهم في
حرب عالميه ثالثه كاترين حنه الجزيره كييف